children between the ages of 8 and 18
spend on average around eight or nine
hours a day on screens I've seen some
estimates that say 10 hours and that's
just for entertainment purposes
doesn't count score it's even harder to
find Reliable estimates for kids younger
than age but we know that they they
don't suddenly jump on the screens at
eight years old and spend eight hours on
them
um so we know that and eight or nine
hours of screen time is probably an
extremely conservative estimate yet even
taking it at face value this would mean
that millions of children are
essentially spending every waking moment
when they're not in school staring at
screens